well ladies and gentlemen if the polls
are to be believed the Democratic party
may be in the middle
of a disastrous collapse where for the
first time in a very very long time the
538 Senate forecast not the house the
Senate forecast has by a very small
margin Republicans now favored to take
the Senate as you might remember for a
very long time for months it looked like
two to one even three to one odds that
Democrats would keep the Senate but
probably lose the house things have
shifted and shifted and shifted to the
point where now if we are to believe the
polling and we will look at that in more
detail
the most likely scenario is Republicans
definitely take the house
and maybe even take the Senate uh by a
52 to 48 margin
Republicans now very slightly favored to
take the Senate it's basically a dead
heat but a far cry from the 70 plus
percent odds that Democrats had to keep
the Senate just some months ago if we
look at the 538 forecast of how the odds
have changed you will see that yes back
in Late July
um it was basically 50 50. and then
Democrats building building building
building a lead all the way up to about
a 71 chance of take of holding the
senate in mid to late September and a
collapse to where now it is Republicans
favored to take the Senate over in the
house the numbers even more dismal for
Democrats now and 84 chance that
Republicans will win the house if we
look at how those numbers have changed
over time you similarly see that it was
getting closer there for a period in
early October
still roughly a two to one margin for
Republicans but now just completely out
of reach 84 percent chance 84 percent
chance for Republicans of taking the
house
one question that many of you have asked
you came to me some of you with tears in
your eyes and said sir can we trust the
polling it is absolutely the case that
when you look at a lot of the generic
ballots which aren't looking at
individual races but they these are
generic Republican or Democratic support
in for example the House vote it is true
that there are some right wing pollsters
sprinkled in
um Trafalgar for example which has
Republicans plus six that's a
right-leaning poll
Rasmussen is a right-leaning poll and it
has Republicans plus seven but many of
what are considered highly rated
non-politically partisan pollsters also
have Republicans leading but by a
slightly smaller margin CNN NPR Wall
Street Journal CBS News all have
Republicans leading but between two and
four in that Congressional ballot so the
most important thing to be asking is
what does this mean for what you should
do what does this mean for what I should
do and it means that we should vote just
worry about you you have one vote make
sure that you use it I have one vote I
will sure as hell make sure that I am
using it and then in six days six and a
half days seven days it'll be Wednesday
morning
um we will all have a very clear picture
of where this all shakes out but I would
be lying to you and I know every time
whenever I do this people write to me
and they say David you bastard
you're discouraging people from voting
by saying Democrats have lost
well I'm not saying Democrats have lost
I'm saying the polling is looking
increasingly bad it's actually a reason
to vote this should encourage people to
vote and then when Democrats are leading
and I report that people write to me and
they say David you bastard you're going
to make Democratic voters
um complacent
where they'll say hey we've got it we
don't need to vote and no no matter what
I'm telling you we should all vote but
there are some really bad looking
numbers Oregon for example there has not
been a republican governor in Oregon or
Oregon as the former president likes to
say Oregon hasn't had a democratic a
republican Governor since 1987. that's
like a hundred years roughly
um think of that we now have a
republican gubernatorial candidate in
Oregon that is favored to win not by a
crazy amount but slightly favored to win
now let's address a couple of issues
related to this first of all I get right
Wingers I see them on the YouTube
comments I see them on my Twitter I see
them on Twitch and they are very much up
in my email
uh gloating
as if I personally
have some particular stake in this that
nobody else has just because I have a
program
um I'm going to tell you guys this again
I will do better in terms of my business
and my show if Republicans win
everything so much like you all were
coming to me in 2016 and gloating about
Trump and much like many of you were
coming to me in 2020 and saying Joe
Biden's going to lose which by the way
you were wrong about I don't know what
these folks are really gloating about
because I have my one vote I have no
special extra votes just because I do a
show and again
I want what's best for the country
what's best for my business is that
Republicans win everything all the time
and Trump comes back and they take the
house and they take the Senate and they
take everything okay I don't want that
but the gloating is kind of weird
because it's just neither here nor there
okay that's number one number two why is
this happening we have a combination of
things
one
again
I just tell things the way I see them
Democrats are terrible on messaging just
absolutely terrible Democrats have
mostly ignored since the Roe v Wade
decision what we know year in and year
out are important economic concerns and
have minimized them to a great degree
now on my show I just give you the
numbers and I say hey you know what
extremely low unemployment nearly full
employment
inflation is high but it's flattening
and it will come down I I just give you
the numbers right but I'm not running a
campaign Democrats went in a little too
hard on Roe v Wade as the defining issue
of the election as I told you over the
summer
the timing may not actually work the
importance of Roe v Wade's repeal May
fade by November 8th and indeed that
seems to be happening and there is a
lack of a sort of escape hatch at this
point for many Democrats who have moved
to the side some of the some of the
economic concerns now a lot of those
economic concerns are based in
misunderstandings like for example that
the economy is a disaster the economy is
doing pretty well gas prices down
unemployment very high new job creation
High I've told but what matters is the
perception of the economy
and by hammering on it Republicans made
have made significant Headway in
addition to that typically
the party that wins the White House gets
crushed in the following midterms it
looked like maybe 2022 would be an
exception but things are Revere uh are
coming back to it's a regression to the
mean you might call it historically it
should be a bad election cycle for
Democrats so that's the combination of
what's going on we will have the real
numbers very soon but if we're going to
lose I want to lose fairly and that
means no armed intimidation of Voters at
the drop boxes and we've got to talk
about that next as many of you know I am
fascinated by cons and scams and
multi-level marketing and all this
different stuff I recently saw Inside
the Mind of a con artist on curiosity
stream it's six episodes and it was
excellent I don't think I would have
discovered it were it not for our
sponsor curiosity stream curiosity
stream has all the newest and best
documentary films they've got the big
titles from the well-known filmmakers
they've got dot valuable Independent
films tons of original content that you
can't find anywhere else when I'm at
home browsing my different streaming
platforms I find curiosity stream to
really have the best selection of
documentaries specifically because
documentaries is all that they have and
they're always adding new titles my
audience gets access to curiosity
streams entire library of documentaries
for just 15 bucks a year that's 25 off
go to
curiositystream.com Pacman or use the
code Pacman the link is down below